the town of regen is dying
I said if someone doesn't do something
this community will be a dead community
I have a paved road from interstate to
region now what do I do to bring people
down 30 miles
[Music]
then it dawned to me nobody is gonna
drive 30 miles for normal sculptures but
they might drive for the world's largest
I started the Enchanted Highway in 1989
I've been at it for 28 years and I takes
me roughly about four to five years to
do one sculpture the first year local
ranchers taught me how to weld I put in
eight hours a day to get one sculpture
done so I use bold oil well tanks I cut
them open and I flatten it out and
that's 90 percent of my metal it's a
passion project right now it started
with that world's largest tin family
the man has 45 feet tall the woman is 43
feet and the boy is 23 feet geese in
flight has over 300 lengths of oil well
pipe on over 15 miles a weld on it and
is in the Guinness Book of Records the
world's largest scrap metal sculpture
that's something I will continue on till
I'm six feet under and then I hope it
continues on after that I want people to
see that this guy who didn't know how to
weld didn't have an art class if he can
create something like this I can do most
anything
a lot of people wonder why I'm living
here because I could live in LA or New
York and be building sculptures there
but the minute I drive up to my little
ranch here I feel like I'm onto
something that's never been done before
[Music]
my name is John Lopez and I'm a scrap
metal sculptor
[Music]
I use a scoop shovel I use snow chains I
use wrenches scissors gosh I use tractor
seats basically anything that is mild
steel it just so happens that I live in
a scrap-metal paradise because every
farmer and rancher in the area has a
scrap metal pile of some kind people are
very generous around here to invite me
over and say you can look through our
scrap pile and so that's where I gather
my materials for my sculptures so then I
bring all this found objects home that
I've hand-picked and I start grabbing
things and fitting them up there it's a
textural experience it's almost like a
patchwork quilt if you will it's got a
little bit of everything in it and
within all that chaos when you step back
the animal comes to life and scrap metal
shouldn't do that
[Music]
one of the most important things for me
is to be connected to the land South
Dakota inspires me I bought an empty lot
on Main Street and lemon and right next
to the park that I put it in was an old
bar called the Kokomo
I cleaned the Kokomo out renovated it
and turned it into a really nice art
gallery where I can feature it show my
finished sculptures I've had people come
up to me and express in emotion what it
means to them or I've had letters I've
seen a lot of scrap metal sculptures
around but I I don't think I've ever
seen anybody capture the life that my
sculptures capture and maybe it will
affect some of the kids that live here
in their life and send them off in a
direction that it wouldn't if I wasn't
living here
[Music]
a lot of the work is quite repetitive
the pleats took about two months to do
probably did those eyes ten times even
the texture of the skin their graceful
dancing which I wanted to portray that's
the whole goal is to make them feel like
they're gonna swim away
[Music]
I'm Steven Kessler also known as tusk
I'm a large-scale wildlife sculptor I
found sculpture a little later in life
in my late 30s moving from one career to
the other especially into the art world
that's totally scary and foolish thing
to do I don't think I had an option
after I started sculpting I think my
life was going to be it no matter what I
did sculpture as a whole has inspired me
I mean it's 24-hour thing for me sleep
just gets in the way almost when I'm out
doing day-to-day things not being here
that's always running through my head I
don't know if I'd personally call myself
a daydreamer but I could probably be
labeled one
[Music]
there is definitely a calming with clay
I usually work 12 hours for three days
straight
being able to realize what I want in it
quickly it just seems like it works
together with how I process I've been
involved with making three life-sized
giraffes 40-foot whale shark for manta
rays and we're working on this 30 foot
iguana behind me that back whales took
roughly nine months the inspiration to
do these pieces for the aquarium was
because Utah is a landlocked state
there's a limited number of people you
see these in real life anyways to be
able to be in the same room feel the
size of it hopefully there's an energy
to it and hopefully inspire conservation
packs because of it if someone says oh I
can't sculpt this had to be tried by it
you know you never know what's gonna
happen
open the box of clay see what's in it
you know there might be a humpback whale
in the future
[Music]
an S is a place where you have a sense
of protection and strength it's like an
earth temple or a nature temple the wood
is following a pattern but not one
branch is the same it has a nest builder
I'm following those patterns most of the
work is trying to bring out the best of
those shapes with each other
[Music]
I'm Jason fan and I'm a nest builder I
started building nests as a child the
nest building was really an intuitive
process of just gathering branches and
building forts originally and the nest
grew and got bigger and more elaborate
now some of the nests are as big as a
hundred thousand pounds of wood the
hardest part of building the nest is
really gathering all of the wood I use
the chainsaw to cut wood I use a machete
to cut off all the excess leaves and
from there I really assess you know what
kind of shapes I have what kind of
material I have to work with the
construction process of the nest first
is creating the foundation and the
infrastructure and then I follow those
larger sculptural shapes that I bolt
together with smaller material that I
can weave in and around I use every part
of the tree the trunk of the tree all
the way down to the very smallest twig
and branch of the tree I've gotten to
where I'm used to building them on
flatbed trailers and moving them around
and in many cases I'm transporting them
across the country because the nests are
quite heavy if I use cranes and
forklifts
different kinds of equipment this is all
eucalyptus there's over 75 different
species of eucalyptus on this property
I've built around 50 nests all over the
country and now primarily I build the
nests with kids within educational
setting
as an educator like it's really
important to work with kids and help
them realize that they have the ability
to shape and create an environment I'm
going to show you how we can integrate
those branches and to the spiral
I love getting kids out into nature
interacting with nature and and the nest
is actually very much a collaboration
with nature I know I've done a good job
when it looks like the nest is something
that could almost have grown out of the
ground
[Music]